[Music]
president biden's approval rating is
sinking fast as multiple crises pile up
and it could screw things up for
democrats in the midterms next year the
real clear politics average shows
biden's approval slipping below 50
percent for the first time this year
that's on top of democrats already
sounding the alarm about their terrible
messaging rising crime the border a
spike in covet cases greg
he says his poll numbers are sinking
faster than brian stelter in a
mcdonald's ball pit
i just wrote that one down i thought it
was okay um you know the demo you know
with our government they didn't plan an
exit strategy for kabul but they should
start planning a new exit strategy for
the democrats in the house and the
senate uh in this and
when they leave dc oddly enough people
are craving stability
which was kind of what joe was promising
in the good old days you know we
understood that trump was a chaos engine
he was doing five things at once you
know trump shook the box
biden promised just to lay in it
and uh you could say that the presidency
ages the man i'm hoping that joe is
benjamin button because i don't see him
getting much older
again a relatively obscure cultural
reference
i got this one
thank you
um i would say you forgot one thing that
they have and that is
excuse me redistricting right so that's
happening this year and so republicans
are already kind of with reason
measuring the drapes for some of these
districts in the house that they are
targeting um and the recruiting on
behalf of kevin mccarthy the minority
leader in the house has is very good for
the the times
diverse candidates and candidates with
military backgrounds so it was already
going to be very difficult for president
biden to try to get through this massive
agenda you've got the infrastructure
bill the debt ceiling issues coming up
reconciliation they want to do the
voting bills that they want to do but
you add a kabul commission
to the mix and it's going to slow
everything down
uh geraldo i know this isn't a worry for
you but inflation didn't i forgot i
forgot that but 86
86
well as you take that five ski out of
your wallet it's worth less so thank you
very much justin
86 of paul those people pulled by fox
were concerned about inflation and
people are getting hit seriously hard
and like buying groceries and things
like that
well i i don't know what milk costs
because i i don't shop i don't like
shopping and now you order it from the
amazon anyway but gas is where people
see inflation
yes i get gas from sales prices
when you see a guy when you see a gallon
of gas it's over three bucks
a minute uh
everybody around me i i i hear i hear
that that poll result and i i discredit
it i i think that what people care about
is is chaos at the border
uh they they care about kabul will be a
huge topic so the people will bring in
shame and the republicans will shame the
democrats for running away and so forth
uh but i i think that uh
biden is in trouble redistricting is
gonna be a
big thing and i think the republicans
will sweep back in power and i i think
that talking about inflation the 3.5
trillion dollar
package they're trying to put together
that's what scares people
yeah that's a jesse that's a
that is
afghanistan is kryptonite to moderate
democrats they're not going to go near
that that's my prediction but final word
to you the biden slip started in may
june with the right track wrong track
question that they asked and it was
going well remember juan used to come on
the show and say it's going to be the
summer love america's back baby that's
not what happened it started to
deteriorate big time right when the
border catastrophe was at its zenith gas
prices started to go up and labor
shortage small business couldn't find
workers so people were pessimistic then
as greg mentioned you get into august
late july he flip-flops on masks as
delta comes up and then afghanistan just
put them below 50
people are feeling insecure
and they're not stable and all the
republicans have to do is say joe biden
inherited
a recovering economy a vaccine a secure
border and a strong foreign policy and
he squandered it and as republicans
here's what we're going to do to make
your life better and all the money that
they spent and want to spend is driving
up inflation real wages adjusting for
inflation have fallen seven months in a
row so people are there it's eaten into
their paycheck consumer confidence is a
10-year low wow as of last friday so
boo bad
fastest up next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else